a ton that's what I do when I'm at home
I read a lot I listen to albums and I
read music and I say albums do you have
like a record player I have a record
player and a thousand albums sorry about
a thousand holy yeah enjoy it give
like a room that you go to you know I'm
going to I'm moving into a new house
which will be have a specific room that
I will go into to strictly play guitar
and listen to analog yeah if you do you
know Henry Rollins at all I do know
Henry Rollins well you say friends I
mean but I do know him he's an
acquaintance of mine he's a fascinating
guy he's a fascinating guy good man very
good that dude very inspirational guy
too inspires me
I dig him I didn't interview with him at
Largo
I dig him big-time he's got these crazy
quarter-million dollar speakers in his
house yeah like there's a speaker room
yeah look at this this is the room so is
all these albums and those those
gigantic things by the way the dude on
the right I think is Robert hilburn who
was the critic for the LA Times that's
how much I dig music I think that's
Robert hilburn I'm pretty sure so Henry
gets Henry who obviously became famous
great job - he wrote the great Johnny
Cash book that came out of here as good
as I saw you dig Johnny Cash by the
pictures on the well love Johnny Cash
yeah I had a dog named Johnny Cash just
died recently
unfortunately my granddaughter's name is
Johnny Cash um that those those speakers
are crazy look at these speakers
he's got yeah I just got new speakers
and they were like 8000 for a pair and I
thought I was not look at the size of
that that's ridiculous
that's why she wondered granite says
like 2001 a Space Oddity yeah looking
speakers I want to go over his house but
I don't want to ask I don't want to be
like Henry come on bro let me call your
house I don't want to be that weird guy
I'm looking for the Bay avoids because I
know I downloaded them and I want to own
them but how many people do you think
owned those speakers I mean I thought
but that person if you have to be
wealthy or
that's where you want to put your money
click on that yellow one that you just
what's that oh that's the same speaker
except in yellow oh those are a big ball
around because they
look like Plumbing Supplies do they
don't look good I don't think they look
I think they look good I think they look
futuristic
again now here we go why we get fat